we have undertaken a historic effort to
massively reduce job crushing
regulations sounded good to me but the
media says Trump's wrecking America this
is a very big deal the Environmental
Protection Agency just rolled back Obama
era climate rules he single-handedly led
the world down a dark path his proposal
is literally insane we're told his
deregulations an attack on the
environment that workers health safety
and pay or casualties even the Trump's
trying to kill us now Trump has cut
regulations he promised to shrink the
regulation rulebook back to the size it
was 58 years ago we will have a great
regulatory climate one two three the day
he got elected you saw the stock markets
swing up Grover Norquist runs a group
that fights for lower taxes and fewer
rules Trump set a message to business
we're not going to crush you and that's
caused growth that was the beginning of
a recovery the 48 hours since Donald
Trump was elected to the oval office the
stock market has rallied reaching new
heights and the Trump administration has
repealed lots of rules for example
waters of the United States we're gonna
protect waters the United States sounds
good they were including little trickles
the kind of ponds that spring up and
when it rains a lot one night then it
goes away the next day they were using
it as a land control land control can
crush people Jill and Jack Barron were
encouraged by Idaho officials to clear a
drainage ditch but when they did that
federal officials went after them
finding them thousands of dollars 37,500
day until the Barons had to sell their
home and move into this trailer but now
thanks to deregulation they can use
their land again good but other repealed
rules sound important the names for all
these regulations are written by the
regulators their advertisements for
themselves but unlike many advertisers
regulators don't list the side effects
some people
changes in behavior hostility agitation
may cause unemployment may reduce wages
may raise the cost of energy may make
your car not drivable
well it's drivable but smaller because
the Obama rules would have forced car
makers the nearly doubled gas mileage
and more people are killed in smaller
cars should the government tell you what
kind of car to buy should they I mean
that's what a regulation does now
California regulators have made a deal
with four automakers to keep the Obama
rules in effect telling Californians
some cars you cannot have net neutrality
for everyone Trump's FCC also ended net
neutrality rule they were going to turn
the internet which is a free largely
free and open operation into a
government regulated utility monopoly
when Trump repealed that people said he
was handing the keys to the internet
over to a handful of multibillion-dollar
corporations well bad things were going
to happen they were going to charge you
to do this that and the other thing the
companies would send your email slower
than somebody else's none of that's
happen none of it none of it none of it
none of it they're two for $5 mixing
that's to you for McDonald's is that
many regulations were repealed the few
people know about one would have treated
franchise companies like McDonald's is
one single business why the trial
lawyers want to be able to sue all of
McDonald's not just the local McDonald's
if they spill coffee on themselves and
the labor unions wanted to unionize all
of McDonald's not just the one store
that would have been a disaster that was
ended big regulation it's when we remove
those bad rules so that corporations can
maximize their profits people think
Trump is destroying the workplace and
the environment if you get your news
from late-night comedy shows you think
that you regulation is bad for the
economy and bad for the environment
important in fact it's good for the
environment it's good for jobs it's good
for people having more wealth but we
want the air to be cleaner the air is
getting cleaner it's dramatically
cleaner it is mostly because of EPA
rules past decades ago
and every time someone replaces an old
car with a new one the air gets a little
cleaner now climate change and whether
we can do anything about that's a
separate debate but when it comes to
clean air
Trump's undoing of Obama's ever stricter
standards just returns us to the rules
in effect during the Clinton Bush years
were you coughing then no but the media
don't tell you that President Trump has
liberated American factories from the
scourge of pollution
lost in the coughing is the unfortunate
fact that Trump's adding regulations too
so all about made in America so now
government agencies have to buy more
american-made stuff that sounds like a
good idea but it said on my DNA wish she
hadn't done it that is not deregulation
that is regulation Doc's humbly today
markets that rose when he was elected
have dropped is Trump's tariffs punish
American companies that buy steel and
consumers who want things like washing
machines and solar panels there is a
challenge Trump is a protectionist in
many ways and then I can always do much
more or I can do less depending on what
happens with respect to a deal and tax
the tariffs or taxes and regulations on
the border are regulations on consumers
and frankly it hasn't cost our consumer
anything of course China the good news
is the vast majority of the regulatory
acts by a factor of many have been
deregulatory and they've been
tremendously helpful and yet with all
this publicity about Trump deregulating
he hasn't done that much he's done a
great deal more than anybody in recent
history maybe even more than Reagan did
we have cut 22 regulations for every one
new regulation think of that one he
exaggerated as usual the real numbers
about 5 repealed for every new one
passed but that's still pretty good
he's loosened all these rules it's good
whatever excessive regulations are cut
regulations are like taxes they take
choices away from the government takes
your money you don't get to decide what
to do you have to go work more hours
spend less time with your family less
time of things you
do they take your time they cost us
money deprive us of opportunities they
take our freedom